Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is radio
lab. Robert is traveling, uh, today.
So it's just me and, uh,
today we have a very different kind
of story than we've ever done. Uh,
it comes from a journalist and
filmmaker named Luis trays.
And an interesting thing kind of
happened as we were reporting.
This sounds pretty clear. Yeah. It's
gotta be a landline. Luis and a,
one of our producers, Tim Howard had, uh,
called up this Guy
Vladimir [inaudible], uh,
who is a filmmaker
himself, Cuban guy, exile.
And the interview happened to
be just a few hours after, um,
Obama had made that
big announcement today,
the United States of America is changing
its relationship with the people of
Cuba
and the most significant changes in
our policy and more than 50 years that
happened just before the interview.
Hello? Is this Vladimir? Hey,
we're recording. Yes, it's flooding
me. Vladimir, how are you doing?
This is Tim in New York, and we
also have Luis. Hi. [inaudible].
It's a if Lewis, how are you Lewis?
Good. Good. And love the news now. Yeah.
Amazing News, right? I was crying.
Really? Yeah, I was crying, man.
Yeah.
First of all, you know,
I've been here in the United
State for 20 years and I never,
never think that I was gonna
see the state. You know, really,
we will begin to normalize relations
between our two countries because east has
been 55, 50 year, 53 years
since the United States.
You know, bro,
the relationship with diplomatic
relationship with the [inaudible]. Yeah.
And nothing happened in Cuba. You
know, everybody sees it the same.
No.
Everything is going to change.
[inaudible]
today, a collaboration, uh,
with, uh, a fantastic program.
Radio and Volante Luis
tress comes to us from them.
This is a story that predates the stuff
you've been hearing the news in many
ways. It's maybe a tiny dark
amble too. All of that stuff.
It's a story about Cuba,
the power of music and a group of Cuban
kids who decide to opt out in this crazy
way that when Lewis Tris told us
about it, we almost couldn't believe.
So the reason we called up laddy is that
we wanted to hear the backstory of all
of this. Wow.
I was pouring peanut Rio in 1964 tell me
about what it was like for you to be a
kid.
I wasn't happy because in Cuba
we didn't have any information.
We didn't have any communication
with anybody else. High Q1. Right.
And anybody seen that we receive it was
the, you know, the news that they go,
I mean, want to give us to us
[inaudible] he remembers listening to
endless field Castro's
speeches on the radio.
I remember when I was a kid in elementary
school all the time they were teaching
us that
Rochelle [inaudible],
what's the big country in
the world? The big economy.
And every scene we would hope
east to be like, Dang. Yeah.
It was a given that he would get in
line every year to get his story.
You know, are you only got three toys
every year because of rationing. Exactly.
And then every week he and
his folks would wake up,
they would go to the Knicks nearest church
to throw eggs at the church building,
throw eggs at the church. Why? Because
we didn't believe in God, the government,
they didn't believe in
God. You know, that's,
that's how you showed you were a good
revolutionary and Vladimir was just being
a good boy.
But when he turns 14 there comes a day
when a friend takes him aside and shows
him a video of led Zeppelin.
I remember that day. I remember like,
do you remember what lights up on Song?
It was costumer
[inaudible] cashmere. Oh yeah, yeah.
Coaching was my first
time and I hear the music.
How did it, how did it make you
feel when you heard cashmere? Whoa.
Differ.
You know, you see role playing and you
see you me page with those long hair.
They moved on. They had,
I gave her a rabbit and
the scene love, they say
you must read different
[inaudible].
And because his dad
was completely changed,
[inaudible]
completely changed my life. Let me
tell you, completely changed my life.
He's not sure why,
but in that moment I went from English,
Islam to Freaky,
freaky and went to freaky. What
is, what is freaky? So freaky.
These are what Cubans call
the most extreme metal heads.
Hard rock punk rockers. We start waving
the close close with
whole a long hair problem.
Was that given the Cuban one radio
station didn't put any rock music down.
I remember when I was 19
years old, 20 years old,
my father giving a Russian
radio and he was a good at fam.
We went to the,
to the roof or some friends because
in those rooms you can listen today.
A station from Florida.
Yeah. Oh Man.
We've listened. Running style.
A sympathy with the devil. Yeah.
Hello. Hello.
Hello baby man.
Mighty man. You know we
were decided though. Listen,
Berryman and I said that I
didn't like it in the beginning.
Everything that came from there
in English, it was good. You know,
because I don't know that King of Muesli.
Give us another
door.
Two ladies walking around with ripped
jeans, long hair. And that's fine.
It's a normal youth rebellion.
But then in the late
eighties everything changes.
Mr Gorbachev Open this gate.
[inaudible] Mr Gorbachev
tear down this wall.
The Wall Berlin Wall went down.
They are here in the thousands.
They are here in the tens of
thousands and in reaction. Hey
[inaudible] smoke the
Casto government. Dugin
[inaudible] [inaudible] says
[inaudible] one thing or death.
The slogan is painted freshly all
over Havana, socialism or death.
Suddenly music you listen to became very
ideological and if you listen to rock,
you were listening to the
enemy of the Cuban state.
The United States government created a
police presence in every neighborhood,
every five blocks, and Vladimir says,
the police found you and you had
long hair. They'd beat us, kick us,
send you away to work, putting
sugarcane in the cane fields.
That's like that booth in school. They'd
often cut your hair against your will.
He wasn't abused.
And just to jump in, this is the point
in the story where things take a very,
no other way to say it, a very punk rock
turn, because into this cultural war
step's a guy named Papa
Papa. We name me, he knew
Popolo Papa Labella, you
know Popo the bullet.
I really want to say that
he tried to embody that,
that kind of bullet to
your brain that wake up
[inaudible].
That's Bob Mariano. He's a professor
at southern Oregon University.
He went several times in the 90s to Cuba
to interview papa who he calls the Kurt
Cobain of the free keys.
Yeah. He looked very intense.
Who was cocky and confident and just
charismatic. Super Tall. Skinny.
Yeah. He always wear a American
flag. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
He like a Bandana.
Use Holly User two friends [inaudible]
his sous Diaz and Lisa Nandis who is also
a bad native is [inaudible] Eh
[inaudible] so Louis remembers the first
time he met [inaudible] and it was on a
night that uh,
Communist Party meeting was taking
place right outside his house.
Outside the building. Outgoing
Gwen Papa's coming. He's coming
in a bicycle and we, he's,
hey a fly United state flat.
He's coming on his head. Yeah, my father,
my father going down a second
deal. [inaudible] your father,
your father, he had when he started
going with the American flag on his head.
[inaudible] I do crazy digging.
You flat out row our you head in bubble
say y y everyone outside the building.
Silings
Papa was, it was a weird guy.
[inaudible] giving you a
hug in the body. When we do,
you can see video of Papo because Vladimir
shot a documentary in 1994 where he
interviewed Papo and some of the other
freebies and in that documentary,
papa talks about growing up poor father
and he's an alcoholic, mother abandon
[inaudible] by age 14 he's in the
streets and a few years later he makes a
decision that's really at
the heart of this story from
[inaudible] just to set it up so that
you can understand the context yet
what happened was that 1989 I
think 1990 somewhere around there,
the Cuban government
is fighting in Angola.
It's backing a leftist liberation movement
and it's kind of a proxy war with the
United States and in the late eighties
Cuban soldiers started coming back home
and some soldiers from the Cuban
army they're wearing in Africa,
they came with HIV,
HIV positive. Because of that,
the government has all the
[inaudible] tested with HIV.
If you belong to a high risk group,
you were tested. They went to the,
to your place of war, they went to your
apartment, they went to the school,
they went to everybody. Wow.
I remember if they went,
they went to my ward and they test
everybody over there and they run your
station. 50 people's over there. Wow.
Give me your blood. Give me your bro.
Give me your broke. Give me your
blood. Bloody says they would come in,
take your blood and if they
found that you were positive,
the police came to you in the, in the
police car, go straight to the cemetery.
They just locked you up.
Yeah, and I remember,
I remember one day I was talking to
him Papo and his wife. I said, look
[inaudible] I want to leave free.
Look, they're kicking me out.
They're beating me out. They don't,
they don't want me to
leave like a rocket here.
They are doing a lot of things to
me. I'm going to do a lot of things.
[inaudible] and he told me, look,
I went to this rock concert in via Clara.
Papa told him I met up
with these other Rutgers,
they were HIV positive and
I went and took a syringe,
drew some blood from their arm and I put
the needle in my own arm and I jammed
myself with HIV. I get my tail,
we would blow contaminated
with you. Did HIV, you know,
and I look at him said,
do you know what you did?
Do you know what you doing? You're
going to die man. I ain't said to me,
I don't care. That's
crazy. That's crazy. He,
he knew for sure that
when he did that that he,
that that was a death
sentence for him. Yes.
He knows Vladimir is not quite sure that
the others that came after Papo really
knew what they were doing but, but papa
knew, remember he says Saas Helene's
death and he proposed
to me death is a dog.
[inaudible]
when you don't have any more
doors to open, death is a door
coming up. That door gets wider,
others walk through and for at least a
beat, they find something besides that,
something quite the opposite.
[inaudible]
message one hey,
my name is [inaudible] and Radiolab is
supported in part by the [inaudible]
foundation and have public understanding
of science and technology in the modern
world. More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotlone.org Radiolab is
produced by W NYC and distributed by NPR.
And this method.
Hey, I'm Chad. I'm Rod. This is Radiolab.
Yes. One, two, one two. Mike Chick.
That's Lewis trace of radio on Bellante.
Let's go back to his story about Cuba
and music in the late eighties and
nineties and so far a dude
has made a crazy decision,
dude named Popo to inject himself
with HIV. Would you call the protest?
I think a papa would have called
it a protest, but not the,
the guys that came after
this is at a moment when there was a
cultural work happening between the Castro
government and anyone
eat deemed antisocial,
which included included kids with
long hair who listened to rock.
And it was also a moment where if you
were found to be HIV positive in Cuba,
you were forcibly quarantine.
So poppo injects himself and
he gets sent to the sanitarium.
And can you describe that place?
Like what did he find? Well,
he found a beautiful place in the
middle of the [inaudible] countryside.
Really? It's full of
palm trees, very green,
very lush farm animals roaming
in. And you went there?
Yes, yes I was there. I was there.
And there are still farm animals.
They would Romaine, a
couple of cows and chickens.
It's like kind of an idyllic place.
So I went there to visit the last two
rockers that still remain the place are
some go way out and his wife Yolanda,
and they're kind of like the keepers
of all that went down in there,
the memories. So I spent a couple
of days with them and they,
they walked me around and it's full
of like these little housing units and
you're saying this place
was idyllic even back then
[inaudible] are walking me
through it and you're like, okay.
So we would be walking around here 10
years ago and Nirvana would be coming out
of here.
TELECO would be coming
out of the next house.
Didn't see separately
[inaudible]
no kidding. Yeah. So it was like
a headbangers ball and the rear,
you know, wait, why?
How come they were able to have that
freedom in the sanatorium but not outside.
Initially the sanitarium system was
under the military and it was more of a
gulag. But in the late
eighties, early nineties,
the sanitariums went from the military
being in charge to the Ministry of Health
and medicine. And these
were by all accounts,
very progressive doctors, very
concerned about their patients.
They gave them all the food and
medicine they needed and they were like,
you want to rock out? Go
ahead. So it was like a prison,
but it was also kind of a little bubble
of freedom. And strangely enough, they,
they soon found out that
they even had power. Nope.
No police power. They didn't have
before. Laddy told me the story.
Um,
patients who said the sanitarium could
go out every 21 days for a day trip and
some of the freak keys would go out and
just by flashing their ID cards that
said they were aids patients,
police would leave them alone.
I remember in two or three occasions that
the police came after name and one of
them have, say a Guineans, a Syringe,
syringe full of blood,
and Vladi says the guy took out the blood
and waved it at the police and said,
you want to come to me? Come in, came
to me. And they were afraid of that.
And so word began to spread about what
life was like inside the Santeria.
And you have to keep in mind that
outside Cuba was falling apart.
Hard economic times in Cuba,
the government today tightened red
rationing and raised egg prices.
It blamed delays in
Soviet shipments to Cuba.
Almost overnight after the
fall of the Soviet Union,
Cuba was left without the massive
subsidies that used to get that man
long lines for bread. Oh, a short temper.
Or we were suffering that immersive
survivors who never actually lived inside
the sanitarium. He says that people
outside were going hungry and he himself,
I was waiting like a hundred
pounds, 98 pounds. Oh my God.
And things just kept
getting worse. You'll see
hungry sunburn, dehydrated.
50,000 people leave Cuba.
They managed to escape on a raft and
make it to the Florida keys these days.
More Cubans than ever
are taking the risks.
It was the big group crisis,
you know, in the Clinton era.
But if you were in the
sanatorium you were fine. Yeah,
just being able to get
milk and egg and beans.
Valerie Yanno says that that was one of
the big motivation for a lot of kids.
Yes. I'm not going to be
harassed. Yes, I'm free. And yes,
I also get meals and it went from
being a couple of self injectors,
a couple of dozen self injectors
to being hundreds. Hello.
And did the government know
that this was happening?
Well
[inaudible] there's this
Swedish documentary from
the time it's called Sociale
East [inaudible] and in it
there's this bishop of Abana
[inaudible] [inaudible],
his last name is [inaudible] and he says
that he met some of the kids that were
injecting themselves with aids and that
at a state dinner he approached Fidel.
He told him
[inaudible] did these kids stare at
during injecting themselves and, and
[inaudible] [inaudible] couldn't
believe it. Like what does
[inaudible] say to you?
And then after that in the pharmacy,
they don't sell cerise anymore.
They put a low def [inaudible]
in gather salvage HIV.
You want to spend eight years in prison,
but it didn't matter.
It was like a movement
[inaudible]
and all of a sudden you have all these
bands forming across the island in
different sanitariums in the biggest
one at the mall in Santiago, La Vega.
Let's go costs, which is like a
half hour, 45 minutes south of five.
I know you have the first group that
gets formed, it's called [inaudible],
which translates to HIV
[inaudible]
but then in central of the island
in this town called Santa Clara,
you had the Cuban punk band is cornea
and the scoria translates as scum,
right? Scoria and according to Bob,
if you look back to the eighties the
people who were fleeing Cuba about Ceros
the rafters, one of the responses of
the Cuban government were billboards.
That's at Camp Lai. Scoria
[inaudible] let the scum leave.
So to call yourself a score,
[inaudible] call yourself that
is punk rock.
And were these bands a big outside?
The sanitorium too is Scoria is,
I mean you can't talk about Cuban
punk without, I mean a Skoda is like,
so their tapes got out or something.
Yeah, totally. It would have is next.
I mean these bands are forming,
kids are self-injecting does it just keep
growing and growing? Yeah, but are we,
I don't have [inaudible] yet.
[inaudible] there's tape of uh,
her son on Yolanda saying that it got to
be so fashionable that kids started to
think that in order to be a
freaky you had to have aids. Yeah.
I know that there was
[inaudible] saying Amy
[inaudible], which is, and
the kids were saying that
really want it to be a rocker. In that
time you had to have aids. It's like the,
the fact that it went from
10 or 20 to 200 or more.
It was obviously like
this kind of just, um,
joiner phenomenon of like, that's so
cool. I'm going to do it too. And then
[inaudible] [inaudible] there was even
talk among some of the young people I met
of thinking that, oh, eventually feed
ELL and those guys will find a cure.
You're going to find a cure
for this. Cuba with a bell,
one of the best health care
systems in the western hemisphere.
We're going to leave forever.
When everything started to change,
when the first of them died
[inaudible]
according to [inaudible], the
first kid that died in [inaudible],
the view was a guy named Manuel. We
don't know his last name or his age.
He was the first one. The second
day I wanted to set a date,
anybody to stop at one point
in Hillary's documentary,
which was made in 1994
[inaudible] that in two years
[inaudible] about 18 people died
[inaudible] and on their style scene,
how you die because you don't die like a
normal person and had a heart attack or
anything. No, you transform yourself.
A lot of them went blind.
Then they went insane.
They started getting opportunistic
diseases. You know how eats works.
Seeing that as Dan sinking
and my, what they did
[inaudible]
did kids start saying they wish
they hadn't done this? Well,
when you see bloodies documentary
and that Swedish documentary,
sociologist one went to
summit in 1995. Yeah.
You definitely see the
kids having deep regrets.
You have one of them saying,
you gotta be entirely
[inaudible]. I regret this.
I regret it a million times.
[inaudible] how about Papa?
Well, I don't, I never heard Papa, uh,
ever questioned that he had done it.
[inaudible]
and in that Swedish documentary,
there's a scene towards the end
where you see poppo and he's sick.
He's real thin. His face is swollen.
I remember he's had like [inaudible]
and stepping into an evangelical church.
He's wearing a nirvana tee shirt, but
he's become a fervent Christian man.
He's found this community of Evan Delco
Christians that accepts aids patients is
still taunting the government
because he says, oh,
you still a rocker. And that he thinks
that Christ is the perfect communist.
More communists were like the
Christians. That would be perfect.
It's interesting though,
because in that last video we also
see him taking English classes.
Oh, you fine.
I know. And he's saying like, you know,
I told him from the other patients in the
sanitarium, they're like sick like me.
They won't go out at night.
They won't rock out
till the early morning,
but I'm like going know this is my life.
So he was sort of defined
to the end. Yeah. C a
[inaudible] and a few months later,
or according to Gerson bubble
started to bleed out from his mouth.
He but do it online too. They
lay down the an eyes book
[inaudible] he had a
parasite in his brain.
He became a violet and he
died from that disease.
So it's like, I want him and he going,
I'll say, yeah, part of me wonder.
It's like,
is this strong and fierce or is it
just dumb and sad and maybe fear.
It's also like, I can't figure
out how to feel about this. Yeah.
Well I think it can be
all those things, right?
It was dumb and stupid and immature and
it was also nihilistic and an archaic.
You think in the end it had
any impact? Well, that's,
that's hard to say. Um, it must have,
it must have.
Here's how Lewis puts it. Not
even five years after Papa died,
things did start to shift in Cuba.
Make it a bit what you will.
But December 8th, 2000,
Castro unveils a statue of John Lennon.
That same year,
Bob Mariano and a bunch of rock musicians
including will Oldham, David Paho,
they were given permission to play a bunch
of rock shows in Cuba out in the open
and at one of those
shows and Pinar del Rio.
I announced, listen,
we're going to send out this next
number to Papa labella and the free keys
[inaudible]
and uh, everyone sang along.
Now it would be impossible to draw any
kind of cause and effect and say one
thing led to another that
would be ridiculous. But
Luis says that back when this free keys
were streaming into the sanitorium,
Cuba wasn't changing back then.
It started to change precisely because
of a hundred gestures big in small.
He says around Cuba at that moment,
there are all of these tiny,
mostly silent protests taking hold.
And then you have the Maliko Lasso,
which was like the first serious civil
disobedience that Castro had in in 94,
where the mob in Havana rose up because
they were so tired of the power outages.
They were angry at their poor living
conditions. They were leading the, uh,
the city in rafts by the
thousands, by the hundreds.
Castro literally had to come down to
the Cuban Malica and the beautiful, um,
uh, seaside road that, that
circles around Havana and he,
he literally had to talk the mob
down to, at this moment, you know,
late eighties, early nineties,
th there's this breeding ground
of discontent all over Cuba.
And I think the self injector movement
is the best crystallization we have of
that. Yeah.
It's like the sort of a thousand points
of light and this is the brightest
point, right? Or the darkest point,
frankly. Yeah, right, exactly. Dude. Off
[inaudible]
huge thank you to Luis
trays of radio and Bellante.
We were thrilled to collaborate with Radio
Malott Day and thank you to Daniel LR
Khan for making that
collaboration possible. If you
don't know radio on Volante,
check them out. Radio and bellante.org
they tell these incredible stories, uh,
from around the Spanish
speaking world in Spanish. Uh,
there some very hard hitting stories,
radio and bellante.org we'll also
point you to them@radiolab.org also,
they are a, they've
created a Spanish version,
a Spanish language version of this story
which goes in a different direction,
goes into way more depth into visit to
Cuba and the story of girth and your
Honda, the last two remaining
self infected free keys.
And we may just put that story in our
podcast feed for the Spanish speakers out
there who want to hear their story.
Thank you to Vladimir Sibos and Barbara
Yana for use of their documentaries.
This story was produced by Tim Howard,
who I'm very sad to say
is leaving us this week.
[inaudible] the rains in the building
and I would take the bus here.
Tim, we love you. We wish you the best.
We had production support from
Matt Kielty and Andy Mills,
[inaudible] and original music from
Leo dye and the Cuban punk bands,
HIV and a Scoria Robert Crow, which we'll
be back next podcast. I'm Jad Abumrad.
Thanks for listening.